[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك،
أنا فاشل في دوري أبطال أوروبا، لذا
لا تقلق، استمع إلى ما سأفعله لشرح
سر، لذا مهما حدث فهو
هنا في الفوز بدوري أبطال أوروبا،
فزت بدوري أبطال أوروبا، فزنا بهؤلاء
الأبطال، فزنا  هذا البطل في
دوري أبطال أوروبا ثلاث مرات على التوالي، سأكون
فاشلاً، سأخبرك بشيء
لدي ثلاثة آيدولز في حياتي
مايكل جوردان، تايجر وودز وجوليا
روبرتس، حسنًا، هذا هو آيدولز الثلاثة الخاص بي،
لذلك لسبب واضح مايكل جوردان و
تايجر وودز يملكها وجوليا روبرتس
كذلك، لذلك جاءت جوليا روبرت منذ سنوات إلى
مانشستر
وليس في عام 1890 قلنا أن أليكس ويلسون فاز
بالألقاب والألقاب والألقاب جاءت
في الفترة كما لو كنا أفضل من
يونايتد في هذه الأربع أو الخمس سنوات هه
وهو  ذهبت لزيارة
مانشستر يونايتد
ولم تأت لرؤيتنا،
ولهذا السبب فحتى فزت بدوري
أبطال أوروبا لن تتم
مقارنتها بحقيقة
أن الجواهري يأتي دائمًا إلى مانشستر
ولا يأتون لرؤيتنا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية